Let's explore the opportunities for customization with a
very specific example and the example I'm going to
choose is memory management, in particular how an
operating system handles page faults. Let's say that
this thread executing on the processor incurs a
page fault. The first thing that the operating
system has to do in order to service this page fault will be to find a
free page frame to host the missing page for this particular thread. And once it
allocates a free page frame, then the
operating system is going to initiate the disc IO
to move the page from virtual memory into the free page frame that has been
identified for hosting the missing page from this
particular thread. Once the IO is complete and
the missing page for this thread has
been brought from storage into the free page
frame, the operating system is going to update the
page table for this thread or process, establishing
the mapping between the missing virtual page and
the page frame that had been allocated for
hosting that missing page. Once the page table
has been updated then we can resume the
process so that it can continue where it left off. At the point of the page
fault. One thing that I haven't told you
the sequence of actions that the operating system takes,
is that every so often, the operating system
runs a page replacement algorithm to free up some
page frames. And readiness for allocating the frame
to a page fault that a process may incur.
Just as an airline overbooks its seats in the hope that some passengers
won't show up, the operating system is
also overcommitting its available physical memory hoping
that not all of the pages of a particular process which is in the
memory footprint of the process will actually be needed by the process during
its execution. But how does the operating
system know what the memory access pattern
of a particular process is going to be
in making this decision? The short answer is
it does not. So whatever the operating
system chooses as an algorithm to implement page
replacement. It may not always be the
most appropriate one for some class of applications.
So here is an opportunity for customization depending on the nature of the
application. Knowing some details about the
nature of the application, it might be
possible to customize the way page replacement algorithm is
handled by the operating system. Similar opportunities for customization
exist in the way the operating system schedules processes
on the processor and reacts to external events such as interrupts and so on.